welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on why karoon was
the best character added to the mcu all
year no conscience like i don't
understand why there is no karoon for
blade movement going on right now
because i need to see this man strike
fear into the cold vampire hearts of the
mcu heck yeah
he almost killed an eternal they almost
killed him in his sleep yo he went
straight for kingo he's like yo you look
like a vampire i'm gonna take you out
for the good of humanity that's a good
man
he could probably lift thor's hammer
anyway i don't say it he definitely he
is a man of honor it's true he is worthy
for sure my name is mt and i'm here
today of course with
my favorite person off-screen producer
brandon what's going on hello brenda oh
so happy to be here to close out 2021
with you and the big question already
the end of the year i can't even i can't
wrap my head around that it doesn't make
any sense i think someone's been messing
with the time stream you know we bro it
feels like one division was a zillion
years ago i know but like it was just
wow this year was so long but it was so
good because we had so many good just so
much good marvel content yeah as opposed
to 2020 where we had no content we had
so much to share and boy were we
grateful for it so grateful so grateful
for well with that hit me with that big
question brandon well yeah i mean you
guys could probably already guess you
know 2021 is almost over it's been a
great year for nerd dumb content you
know not just the mcu we had some dc
stuff some star wars stuff you know we
got to see a lot of incredible things
this year uh mostly from our streaming
devices but we did get back in the
theaters that was fun huh hey you never
know what could happen in a movie
theater now you know side story i got to
see like tenant on an imax screening and
no one was there we were in an empty
theater we're the only people there wow
and it was just like we were so happy to
be back at a movie theater even if it
was tennis i really wanted to see tenet
but like eric spoiled it for me during
an episode of something and i was like
well
i have to wait till i forget
i've watched eric's tenant breakdown 10
times and i still don't understand the
movie so there you go okay um good well
yeah we're we're talking the end of 2021
so that leads us to this week's big
question who won the year who had the
best year and all of the nerd dumb which
characters came out on top which came
out on bottom let's figure it out well
the answer to this the the clear answer
um is haley steinfeld this that woman is
on a roll i'm shocked she is on like
she's like the next donald glover like i
don't unders like she's everywhere but
in all seriousness as we bring this here
to her clothes it's time to honor the
heroes and villains that we love so
dearly and try to suss out which ones
had the best year so let's begin with
what matters most when it comes to being
a super powered individual your costume
so brandon who had the best glow up and
we're not talking about powers here this
is strictly a cosmetic alteration you
know because we're you know we're very
fashionable men we got i got the
rockstars
with men of fashion men of class and we
saw some excellent new fits this year
but who should come out on top and some
of the nominees that we got to consider
are of course chongqi and his awesome
dragon scale armor courtesy of mama knew
exactly his proportions yeah what a
smart woman what a smart woman fits
great
normal outfit no nano tech you know he
had to put it on like any any good boy
should uh i do appreciate i mean the man
got to fight in his jordans i mean
that's a pretty good yo you don't see a
lot of jordan fighting that was pretty
sick i love that yeah not since miles
morales was swinging around in his
jordan so we get to see like a superhero
take him out with some some great kicks
on some really good kicks yo imagine
like steve rogers rocking some jordans
while fighting ultron and she's like you
know i was crossing the back
i guarantee you steve rogers he's a he's
a converse all-stars guy i mean you know
oh my god that's perfect he's working
100 yeah he likes the flat foot he likes
1 000 with the star and everything
perfect yeah
then we also have of course sam wilson's
captain america's wing suit at the end
of falcon the winter soldier which was a
pretty big blow-up yeah i mean that was
it that's pretty good you know [ __ ]
you know he he never got his feathers
which makes sense we don't want to see
the feathers ever but as far as like a
globe goes i mean that sue is pretty
good very comic accurate like really
good
uh that that was a good one did we talk
about the thing with the neck and like
how it like it's like cg or something
like that oh the cow yeah because they
had to see
the cg the cow right i think we did talk
about that they were so obsessed with
getting it right that they just made a
cg cow i love it i love it let's let's
do that i finally look so badass in the
comments yeah finally got some sleeves
on my man sam wilson you'd love to see
it you'd love to see it
i mean he's got to pull him up to
intimidate the bad guys you know he's
got to have some sleeves yeah you know
oh i bet they detach so he can like roll
him up to be like all right let's go
time to fight you justin hammer i'm
coming from the sky i'm watching you
from above i think you know the actual
biggest physical like physically glowing
glow up of the year has got to be scar
the witch's final four because that was
quite right when she transformed that's
that's a real glow she was literally
glowing up i mean very much one of it
just gave us a few looks we got to see
her like comic you know her 60s comic
accurate when she was getting ready for
halloween i know uh but like seeing the
uh seeing the scarlet witch actually and
like the outfit was like really cool
with the crown and everything so cool so
rewarding i mean she did a great job
over the years fighting her her cable
knit sweaters and stuff but uh it's good
to see her in an actual
nice comic book style outfit for sure i
think that um scarlet witch's best
outfit was um her modern family just
going crazy sweatpants yeah yeah i think
that was a distressed hair you know yeah
that was a good tear top tier i just
like a good relaxed woman i like a woman
that that feels good in their own
clothes you know i'm saying this is
really comfy it's just having a nice
relaxed time so
comfy wanda is my favorite wheel it
comes anyway of course we also have
loki's bureaucratic office attire
because he's no longer in his uh you
know avengers one
robes of asgard oh look at me no he got
those uh erased by a robot with a smile
you got a suit like the rest of us like
a blue collar job yeah it was nice to
see yeah yeah i mean he looked great i
mean very slick looking love the variant
jacket yeah the kind of like 60s style
you know you said it like bureaucratic
outfit it was it was very cool i liked
it i liked it you know i love his flashy
rocket asgard robes but uh
something like i said imagine if like
this is just how loki dresses in the
future like he just he just ditches the
entire like the
guardian vibe just like i'm just in a
suit now
whatever
i'm making money i like suits i don't
need to wear the the hordes anymore
suits work on him it's tom ilson he's a
very handsome man
but also another handsome person that we
got on the scene is red the guardian and
his vintage armor i think i think it's
fair to say that anyone who's cast in a
marvel movie is probably a very
beautiful hand is there a handsome
person yes i really love that armor in
uh black widow it still fits and it
still fits it's still still fits
yeah black widow had that look it had uh
we got to see black widow and her like
all white
you know
snow cycling
attire which was like she could blend in
with the snow or like if that avalanche
hit no one would be able to never be
able to rescue her
if you're out there skiing this holiday
season please wear bright colors in case
you get covered in an avalanche you
don't want to blend in
but you know you know kingpin's gotta
like that all way attire he loves that
oh yeah he's he's probably uh jealous he
was very jealous oh get up vanessa make
me an all-white uniform
[Laughter]
lastly we got any of spider-man's new
clothes in the new movie this dude is
wardrobe changing like a mother dang in
this movie i don't know what's going on
we still haven't seen the full movie
sign out yet but it will include it in
2021 because it's it's coming but yeah
he's got a lot of new we covered in the
last big question he's got all these new
suits and they look great you'll love to
see new suits on spider-man so which of
these are your personal favorites who
got the biggest glow up of the year
brandon these are tough these are tough
um you know i was really so happy to see
the scarlet witch finally be in like a
scarlet witch appropriate outfit but man
that that captain america wing suit it
hit hit hard it was good i was very
excited to see that i would pick that as
like the best
costume glow glow-up i think
especially from where sam wilson was to
where he ended
beautiful it's great stuff so so
beautiful like i feel like in that
episode where we're seeing that suit for
the first time was like the first time
in mcu history where like seeing a suit
actually emotionally affected me to
someone i mean i wasn't bawling my eyes
out right right but i was like oh my god
this suit is beautiful and we have a
black captain america this is huge so
like no other costume has ever had that
effect on me in the mcu so i've gotta
say sam wilson's captain america for me
as well we're in agreement next category
because you know while we're all here
for the incredible storytelling and mind
bending five sequences we cannot forget
about these adorable sidekicks that we
all fall in love with and this year we
got some pretty good ones i've got to
say because we're talking alligator loki
the most adorable little uh
chompy alligator he'll chomp your hand
right off and then we also have morris
from chongqi the faceless turkey thing
uh makes noises in his best friends with
ben kingsley yeah he was surprisingly
very cute so so cute i i think that he's
probably gonna be in the mcu a lot more
just like popping up i hope he's the new
stan lee might be hilarious
he might get his own spin-off series we
don't know we don't know oh my god
please pet avengers if you're doing a
pet avengers put him on there we also
have sparky from wanda who was very cute
for a very it wasn't a lot it wasn't
around very long but he was pretty cute
he was pretty cute left a mark on me um
i think about sparky every day when i
wake up i do it for sparky sparky wasn't
alive for very long but there was also
senor scratchy he was pretty cute i mean
maybe a demon
a deleted scene he was a demon we
definitely saw him eat a baby keep that
fly he ate a moth fly bug thing but he
was pretty senior i mean your scratchy
was pretty cute i mean i don't know
things that could be demons i'm just
like ah like you lose the cuteness
factor for me that's true um you got to
be why i don't like toddlers
got them
toddlers but i think um for me
uh these last two are the cutest for me
it's gonna be choosing between these two
for me we have pizza dog of course from
hawkeye the cutest winky boy that is my
son if anything happens to him i will
blue skadoo into the screen and fight
all of the the the tracksuit draculas
myself honestly he's too good for this
world and also
king shark from the suicide squad
wholesome and gruesome at the same time
which is why i love him yeah if you're
gonna hate on senior scratchy for eating
a demon what about king shark for eating
whole people whole innocent people hey
those people were mean people no he ate
a freedom fighter oh he did eat the yeah
he did eat them well it was just
sometimes you eat a freedom fighter by
accident it happens it happens when
you're hungry you're not you when you're
hungry you're the snickers not a freedom
fighter king shark was very cute empty
you're right but i mean
for me i'm going to pick my favorite
most adorable sidekick this year i mean
it's got to be alligator loki that was
my favorite oh he's so adorable that's a
good gators that's a good one alligator
low-key ah so adorable like literally
every time i see alligator or loki
gangplank galleon from the donkey kong
soundtrack
in my mind
um because of the the alligators in that
game of crocodiles one of those two i
don't know the difference i think i'm
gonna have to choose
uh pizza dog he's just too cute i can't
he's a winky boy that's my son i'm so
happy to be able to to see him and haley
steinfeld well when he gets revealed to
be a skrull mt you're gonna eat those
words i guarantee you i will cry my eyes
out i will cry only out of one eye out
of respect for for pizza dog uh the real
one that was replaced by a skrull goddam
that'll be so upset don't do it don't do
it don't put that into the world brandon
enough with the cuteness we gotta get to
the action because that's what we're all
here for because there are so many
awesome action sequences this year from
you know natasha bringing down the
entire red room literally via gravity
like if she brought she brought it down
brought it down
bringing
oh sorry what'd you say i said bring it
down the house but it doesn't really
make sense because it's not a house i
guess someone lives there
i mean it was a home for the all those
girls home for all those trafficked
young girls jeez okay it
a prison is technically a home it's just
a bad home that you don't want to be all
these trafficked young women who were
forced into hysterectomies i mean get me
out of this movie seriously we have
natasha bringing down the red room to
the suicide squad fighting star which
was incredible some guy and you know to
loki and sylvie fighting it out while
the multiverse breaks down around them
too many to even count and name so let's
talk about some of our favorites some
fight scenes to consider are sam
wilson's captain america debut because
that [ __ ] was i mean that was she was
amazing
so cool through that throne
the helicopter
of course we have scarlet witch versus
agatha which was you know i mean two
energy beings shooting it out dueling it
out in the sky and then we have shung
chi versus wenmu and the dweller in
darkness which was oh kind of a baller
day for chongqi he took down his dad and
the dweller in darkness well technically
his dad took himself down
but hey you know his sister thinks that
he killed his their dad so that's all
that matters that's whatever sis thinks
that's all that matters and we have the
suicide squad versus starra which i'm
going to let you know right now this is
my personality
hands down
good fight like the
the the gun reveal when blood sports gun
came out like during that sequence and i
was like oh my god it was he just keeps
like adding to it that entire sequence
in the suicide squad versus stara was
phenomenal um then we also have vision
versus white vision in the library which
is more of a philosophical conversation
had some good punches some heavy hits
some throwing around some phasing you
love to see it i mean paul bettany
really hyped us up for that fight
sequence someone who's been dying to
work with so uh
maybe a little over hyped but i think it
was still a good fight it was a good
reveal i liked it i just loved the whole
identity metaphysics conversation
because that's a supervision was he's a
very compassionate person he would
rather talk things through than uh use
violence it was like a star trek next
generation episode just beating him with
logic and i really liked it it was cool
we also have the the recent hawkeye car
chase which is yeah very baller seeing
all those trick arrows was so great
finally seeing a bunch of trick arrows
get used i mean the one shot through
with the car and then on the bridge
so good so good bro i need to see one
arrow with a uh level punching glove on
like a little box box
just like in uh the green arrow in the
the dc
animated series when i was a kid like i
just love a good boxing glove arrow
[Applause]
then we also have you know black widow
taking down the red worm which is pretty
cool it was a really cool fight yeah
falling for a half hour and still
fighting for the long long fall falling
for 30 minutes
i've been falling for 30 minutes for 30
minutes
someone should edit loki falling during
that scenario
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then we also have sylvie versus loki
uh during the you know a couple times
that they did fight a couple times
they came to blows a couple of times but
that last one in front of kang was like
pretty heavy pretty emotionally charged
was all about it he was like oh [ __ ]
yeah king was all of us he was like
what's going on here then we also have
watcher versus ultravision which was
sound good that was
one of the coolest fight sequences you
was ever done i know it was animated but
like more of that energy please that was
some dragon ball z dope ass [ __ ] and i
love that on a creative level let's just
bring that to live action i know it's a
huge ass but like we could do it yeah it
was dope that was dope like the watcher
was
so cool so cool one of the coolest black
superheroes ever yeah i mean i was
excited for the what if series but it
really blew me away it was really good i
really liked it i wish i mean the
episodes were kind of short i wish they
were a little longer because i could
take more but it was great i thought
they did a good job and i'm very excited
to see what the next season of it is
going to bring and how they're going to
bring some of it into the
you know live-action mcu i think we're
going to see some stuff so very
interesting very interesting finally we
cannot have this list without talking
about one of the greatest pieces of
action sequences this year from
invincible invincible versus omni man
that was insanity
i mean um
i'm changing my answer it's it's
invincible period invincible was the
greatest superhero project of the year
for me go watch invincible what do you
think is yours favorite uh action
sequence of the year uh man we've named
a lot of good ones for me i think my
favorite battle sequence of the year
and
you know i might take your old original
favorite and take like the suicide squad
versus star that was very cool i had a
lot of fun with that very well put
together a really good battle sequence
and it was good to see the uh the
suicide squad you know get a little get
a little justice you know what i mean
get a little fairness a little good
representation on on the celluloid
you know what now that we're talking
about the suicide squad i'm remembering
a cute sidekick that sebastian we forgot
to talk about sebastian oh yeah
sebastian i'm changing my answer to
sebastian i love him i'll never forget
about you sebastian i'm waving at you
too but now it is time to talk about our
favorite baddies of the year
i'm not talking about baddies in the way
that you tick-tock generation talk about
baddies
oh
i'm okay no i'm talking about evil
people all right villains
the best part of any series or movie is
the villain but who really dominated the
dark side this year well let's go
through some of our favorites starting
with starro starra was right i'mma keep
it real with you guys i know that you
know murdering people is not right but
a bunch of americans went to space while
he was chilling and took him down and
did experiments on him i would be pissed
too if i broke out of prison
i'm i'd be like [ __ ] all of you guys i'm
going to destroy all y'all because you
all hurt me for several decades yeah a
lot of that was fun a lot of themes of
the villains were right this year
in a lot of them yeah we watched a lot
of villains had a lot of points i mean
you could argue you know agatha harkness
uh on the best villain certainly for
this year but she kind of had a point
too you know you have this crazy lady
running around who's prophesized to like
destroy everything i mean i got that
kind of point like give me that power
i'll take it i'll take care of it just
give it to me give it to me give me your
power come on give me it give me it give
me it
come on give me it i'm sorry please i've
been around for a few years let me
figure this so true yeah that is such a
good point because wanda had no idea
what she was doing
she didn't even know she had done
hurting other people yeah
exactly so agatha's like just stop just
give me the powers go live your life of
being sad and i'm just going to take
these powers because i know how to what
to do with it we also got to talk about
one of the other best villains of the
year our boys email oh man coming in
hard things
great dance
iconic you already know zemo's still
alive thank god but you know he's gonna
bust out a person again and he he was
doing good this year he turned himself
in zemo's just doing z-mobile he's doing
z
he's got a point two he's got a point
two okay
this is true he's you don't want too
much super powered people you gotta kill
the ball don't do that don't kill anyone
the death is wrong and also we have val
um elaine herself in the mcu i'm so
excited to see what they're doing i mean
definitely a villain she's we're gonna
call her a villain oh 100 but then we
also have when whoo
one of the best villains of the year i
felt so bad for this person because like
everyone knows the pain of loss to some
degree and like if there's hope for your
loved one to be alive i don't know about
you but like i would probably do the
same [ __ ] if i was in one situation i
would do the exact same [ __ ] because i'm
i'm a dumbass i feel for you wenwell for
sure and we also have uh the biggest i
yeah the honestly the biggest deal the
biggest villain in the mcu um right now
it is mr kang the conqueror himself
slash he who remains we haven't seen him
do too much yet but what an entrance
what an entrance from our guy jonathan
majors
i think he deserves some type of emmy
recognition um for this because he just
he knocked out the park in one scene i
mean it's got the number one thing you
need as a villain and that's monologuing
baby and he's got it down right he's got
it down right bro if you don't know how
to monologue quit your villain job
go to baskin robbins because that's all
you're good for bro another one since
we're talking about he who remains
i mean
the divorce is final so we can talk
about this miss minutes
uh i mean
she's a villain a villain she's a
villain we were gonna put her in the
cutest sidekicks category but she's
definitely a villain
then we also have the power broker
sharon carter herself yeah very
surprising we didn't all see it coming
uh we'll see what what's in store for
the power broker she hasn't done too
much but i mean the fact that she was
you know remaking powers or the super
soldier serum pretty impressive pretty
impressive stuff i like a strong
independent woman and um
hey it's a girl boss power they also
have um cletus cassidy carnage from
venom two he was a very um hungry mean
man and thank god that he's dead
yeah it was good it was good to finally
see carnage represented on the screen
did they get everything out of carnage
that they could have i don't know i
don't want to say uh but it was good to
see it and then we also of course have
all the freaking villains from
spider-man no way home you got your
sandman you got your electro you got
your lizard yeah you got your maybe
mysterio
i mean he's got to be around here
somewhere because if we're talking about
like people that were killed fighting
peter parker that's the only one that
tom holland's got but yeah who's your
favorite villain of the year my friend
um you know i really wanna
i wanna say i got the harkness just
because she was so great and what a what
a reveal
catherine hunt killing it was so
shocking
but i'm also torn i mean again we
haven't seen spider-man yet but i'm so
excited to see doc back doc and green
goblin together again
for the first time
i'm gonna pull
i'm gonna go doc on this i love you
agatha you're great you're gonna get
your own series we'll get tons more of
you but this is probably our last final
look at doc
the alfred molina version at least so
i'm very excited to have that what about
umt what are you saying i'm gonna say
wanda like wanda was definitely a
villain this year okay juana didn't mean
to hurt all those people but that's just
how her grief manifested so she's a very
tragic
villain i'll never forget watching uh
the the mom from that 70s show just
being like just let us die
this is no you you stay alive mrs
foreman what a shocking reveal and
speaking of shocking reveals mt you know
as we're talking about villains here
maybe a subcategory we should do who had
the most shocking villain reveal who was
like the biggest surprise for you
you know we had like val
showing up that was like a big surprise
we didn't know that was coming maybe
kingpin i think we're gonna see kingpin
in hong kong yeah that was definitely
shocking arms pretty shocking gotta be
kidding me if it's not we had kang
right i mean eric saw it coming three
years ago but uh william king
showing up it was it was that was pretty
surprising white vision uh the power
broker i mean sharon carter being
revealed as the the power broker was so
shocking yeah that was a very big
surprise we had ralph boner that was a
big surprise oh my god
it was boner time at the beginning of
the year the most shocking villain ever
uh and then uh in the post credits for
shanghai we got xiling maybe turning out
to be a villain that was a pretty
interesting little twist to rudy right
there so what do you say empty i think
that the biggest shocking villain reveal
for me
is gonna have to be ralph boner um
because that was that was your big shock
whoa everyone thought it was gonna be
quicksilver from the fox x-men films and
he was just um boner alert yeah ralph
boner for me i think the most shocking
reveal is probably king pin i didn't
think they'd ever do it especially if
it's my boy vinnie d now the caveat to
this answer because we haven't finished
hawkeye yet is if it turns out to not be
kingpin
kevin feige you're the most shocked it's
the aerospace engineer in the suit yeah
yeah
kevin feige will be the most shocking
villain yo if it was kevin feige i would
be 100 okay with that i mean if he if it
is
on the show that's fine if i ran the mcu
i'd put myself in the show too but if
you're making us think it's kingpin and
it's not kingpin you're the villain
kevin you're the villain we've seen a
lot of new characters get introduced
across the nerd sphere this year so who
were some of your favorite new
characters we got chungchi obviously
very new on the scene a lot of people
learned about him this year agatha
harkness of course hitting all these
categories because she is a boss woman
we also i've got xi ling uh from suggy
um then we also have kate bishop kate
bishop i bet you guys know who i'm gonna
pick and then we also have carnage um
who is very new this was the first
live-action carnage that we've ever seen
ever we also have polka dot man which
was r.i.p r.i.p thank you for your
service thank you never forget our
veterans uh peacemaker i heard that when
um rick flack died he said peacemaker
was a super cool dude so um peacemaker
we have yelena whoa that woman knew how
to kick but the star of black widow
period red guardian as well our favorite
man representing russia um he loves the
the motherland then we have sylvie um
the new loki on the scene she kicked a
lot of ass and like then that reveal was
pretty great i loved him like oh here i
am lady loki i'm you and i'm here i am
you
i'm you but better
and we also have wenwoo from
a very tragic villain um t'challa as
star-lord which was a very interesting
new character i really wish that um we
could have seen more of that like but
obviously with chadwick boseman's
passing that cannot happen but it was
very cool to see and hear his voice yeah
that was great for one last time and we
also have karoon obviously mentioned him
up top the man from eternals he's
literally i hope that a croon ends up
becoming eternity um at the end of all
this okay um he just becomes eternity um
then we have eros from the end of
eternals harry styles handsome boy
and uh any of the eternals all of them
uh very new characters um
very cool makari got cersei we got you
know druid all very cool characters but
also we gotta add you know of course i'm
a big fan of invincible we gotta add
pretty much everybody from invincible
yeah that entire
any any character
like it's so they're all unique and
they're so cool adam eve especially
shout out to adam eve very cool freaking
uh damien dark blood so many cool
characters in invincible if you haven't
watched invincible yet what are you
doing if you know nothing about it just
go in blind go watch it oh all those
girls
yeah who is your favorite new character
of the year uh you know i didn't go for
her in the villains category but i think
i mean i got the harkness was like my
favorite new introduction into the mcu
this year i mean so good so great can't
wait to see more of her and i i think
the fact that like the people's love for
her has made marvel be like no no we're
gonna make a whole series with her don't
worry about it she's coming
don't you don't go away
uh so yeah she's she's my favorite new
character for sure love it what about
umt do i even need to ask you you don't
need to ask because everybody knows that
i am a hayley steinfeld
stanfeld i am a big kate bishops like i
i i just love kate bishop before you
know all of this i just love the
character of kate bishop so the fact
that haley steinfeld is kate bishop this
is just the greatest moment of my life
so kate bishop for sure hands down no
contest great there is a hawkeye themed
latest obsession shirt over at
newrockstarsmerch.com people and these
shirts are original designs and have a
limited supply so you'll have to grab
one soon before they're all dead and
gone like armand duquesne or black widow
or a pietro um pick one they're all dead
and they might come back who knows
survive that shirt and other great merch
inspired by loki spider-man and other
cool properties over at
newrockstarsmerch.com next some words
from the people that help us bring big
question to you people like blender's
eyewear it's ski season and blender's
eyewear has all the fresh gear your head
needs to go down the slopes blender's
new snow collection is cleaner colder
and more colorful than ever with three
lines of goggles extra lenses helmets
and beanies blenders is hooking you up
with good vibes all winter here at new
rockstars we got a pair of the moon dog
style glasses and we really like them
they're sturdy comfortable and would
probably be cool on a ski trip though
we've only been testing them in
non-snowy los angeles so very little
snow here very little snow and unlike
expensive brand shades and goggles that
you've lost or smashed in the past
blenders are affordable so you're not
going to cry as much when the inevitable
happens and blender's team of in-house
designers are constantly coming out with
new styles and color ways and choose
from the nebula aura or the all-new
lunar collection so whatever goggle you
choose you're getting gear that elevates
every move you make on the mountain and
it's not just sunglasses or goggles
blenders has prescription glasses
readers and blue lights so live life in
forward motion with blenders today so to
score 15 off your blender's purchase
visit blenderseyewear.com
bigquestionvip that is
blenderseyewear.com
big question vip all one word for 15
off blenders rocked with pride worldwide
a lot of investment apps make it easy to
start trading but just because it's easy
to do doesn't mean you know what you're
doing i certainly don't know what i'm
doing when it comes to trading
investment stuff what what do they call
it stocks i don't know that's what makes
wealthfront different they make it easy
to invest and they make it easy to get
smarter about investing start with
wealthfront's classic portfolio or make
it your own with socially responsible
funds crypto trusts and hundreds of
other investments either way they'll set
you up in minutes with a portfolio you
can count on for the long term
wealthfront was designed by financial
experts to help you turn your good ideas
into great investments without the
hassle of doing everything yourself
you're protected from unnecessary risk
because your portfolio is diversified
across asset classes don't want to spend
hundreds of hours trying to lower your
tax bill they help you do that not sure
how to rebalance your portfolio or what
rebalancing even is they do it
automatically wealthfront is trusted
with over 27 billion dollars in assets
that's billion with a b helping nearly
half a million people build their wealth
get your first five thousand dollars
managed for free at wealthfront.com big
question it takes just minutes to start
building your wealth visit
wealthfront.com bigquestion that's
wealthfront.com
big question but yes these have all been
some great categories but we're here to
figure out just who won the year
completely so let's talk about power
rankings and just who have the biggest
moves and these moves can be up or down
and these will be characters who already
existed in their respective universe not
newly introduced characters okay let's
start with the scarlet witch did she go
up or down
i don't know way up
way up i mean i'm a huge all the way up
all the way up i'm a big scarlet witch
fan from the comics so happy to see her
finally unleashing some of this power
that she has deep down inside of her
yeah way up she went way out super upset
i mean she made kids she was pregnant
for like a minute
it was crazy
crazy stuff you know how many women who
would love to be pregnant for just a day
just like that just uh bang this out
today
that would be great well if we mentioned
her empty we got to about vision do you
think he went up or down
i mean he went from dead to alive so
yeah but
you know he's kind of down again i think
if the original vision is gone if
scarlet vision is gone for now again and
now there's just white vision flowing
around yeah he's out there but he's like
a dumber version of who he was right
he's a blank slate so i think vision
maybe went a little down this year maybe
a little down hmm i think then you have
what if you have ultravision going way
up oh oh way way way up the highest you
can really go really vision definitely
got a um a step down a little step this
year yeah but hey with his memories back
maybe he's on his way up yeah maybe yes
maybe then we have darcy who uh when we
last saw her in uh thor two she was uh
what just an interest just an intern i
mean she went up definitely full on
doctor full-on doctor definitely went up
we had monica rambo who was a child the
last time we saw her now
so she literally went grew up
you know she got she got snapped away
and then blipped back and then got a
little super powered so definitely up
for her a little bit definitely up in
the rankings
and then we've of course got sam wilson
captain america who gotta say definitely
got some upgrades for sure way up
especially after getting those wings
ripped off
[Music]
he's gonna need that upgrade anyway he
definitely might have so way way way up
for sam wilson captain america yeah
bucky what do you think about bucky he
had the save army had from infinity war
yeah yeah bucky is now is fully clean of
his programming as far as we know he's
like fully clean now he's he's got
self-confidence again he believes in
himself he's on the dating scene so i
think he's up a little bit do i think
he's as powerful as maybe he can be no
because you know when he's a when he's a
mindless robot and you're like go kill
he can go kill but now that he's got
thoughts and feelings he's a nicer guy
he's gonna be a little more scared about
his own mortality so maybe he's he's a
better person but maybe not as powerful
that's that's my argument there you know
what that's actually a really good
answer because you're right because he's
i feel like bucky's going through all
these struggles right with you know
trying to be a human being and he
doesn't know how to do that and so you
know that's his like that's what
de-powers him and he's just like all
right i don't want to be a a killer
machine i think right now he's like
captain america at the beginning of
avengers where he's just like hitting
punching bads and feeling bad for
himself he's going to therapy you'll
love to see it hey therapy's great
better person weaker weaker hero that's
all i'm going to say come at me come at
me bucky stan i feel like this is all
part of his character growth like i feel
like this is all just natural character
progression he will he will be way up in
the end don't worry folks way up in for
sure for sure it's gonna it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen you'll get a
new arm it's gonna be great gonna be
great um we also have zemo um which is
you know he definitely went up he went
out he just definitely went out you're
from prison yeah
another prison technically but he had a
fun time in between prisons he's made
some friends which a lot of prisoners
don't get to do he's made friends with
heroes and he's he's going off he's
going up a little bit what about also
from falcon winter soldier i mean we
talked about earlier sharon carter way
up right sharon carter definitely she
went way up as batroc left down to uh on
the ground all right
backtrack how could you all right
rock the leaper
in the arms
fat track a sleeper is more like it
dead got him bad truck the dirt sleeper
well staying in the carter family we
should talk about peggy carter huh yeah
i think that she definitely had a glow
up this year and super soldier serum
tends to do that definitely went up in
the rankings and it seems like she's
maybe gonna be one of the live-action
pullovers from the
what if universe we'll see we'll see who
knows
i mean it would be weird if they didn't
at this point so i mean speaking of
crossing universes what about our boy
the man in your head venom eddie venom
eddie
eddie did he go upward this is a good
question because like depending on like
um symbiote physiology because we he did
have that kid he had a kid he had a kid
this year
a big year for venom had another kid so
does he get weaker when he has children
i don't i don't think he's to be honest
empty i don't think he's any weaker but
i don't think he's any stronger right
now you know the bond is good i guess
they're getting along this is true their
bond is stronger than it's ever been
until he meets his little spidey friend
and learns how to shoot his own webs i
you know venom didn't go up at all he's
he's maintained he's plateau plateauing
right now we need to get him some new
powers and abilities well i know i'm
gonna say venom went up because now he
has uh two chicken friends so that's
true and we also have natasha romano
from the what if series because she's
dead
yeah the main mcu
she definitely got a well she went down
for a little bit after ultron took over
uh everyone will take a dip after that
but then she shot her right back up
played a new universe um that she's
probably gonna get arrested
for being there because she's not
supposed to she's definitely violating
the rules of time and space but i think
she went up a little bit what about our
boy wong huh we've seen a lot of wong
long gets to show up at everything he
wants to be in bro i only know one other
person that has taken down uh emil
blonsky to be abomination and he's a
giant gamma-powered monster uh wong did
that yeah quite easily quite so uh wong
definitely yeah uh but we also have
harley quinn this is a really
interesting one because harley quinn in
suicide squad had a fantastic character
development right all of harley quinn's
journey from birds of prey and all those
movies culminated into this movie and
like i feel like she grew so much as a
character so she's definitely up for
she's definitely yeah all right now this
is a this is an interesting one uh mt
what about loki how do you feel about
loki is he up or down in the power
rankings well which loki are we talking
about we're going to talk about the the
loki that escaped 2012 and is now living
out life in a a new tva branch he
doesn't know where he is how do we feel
about this level big down down b
down and it's so it's i love watching um
avengers one now um oh no in particular
avengers end game because like knowing
the loki from avengers 1 and then seeing
him just like pick up that tesseract i'm
like you just picked up your ticket to
hell and you deserve this for everything
you did at avengers 1. you took out that
guy's eye bro no this is exactly what he
deserved for me anyway so like seeing
him go through that character
development while you know basically in
hell has been quite enjoyable for me i i
agree with umt i think loki's a little
down in the power rankings mainly
because his perspective has changed so
much you know he was a very powerful
person where he was and what he knew of
like time and space but now that's all
changed and he's just uh you know he's
working for the man now he's working for
the tva sort of uh he helped break apart
the the multiverse which you can argue
is a very powerful thing to do i don't i
in my opinion he's not more powerful now
i think if anything what he has to like
visualize and encapsulate now is so
insane that he's less powerful i think
it's kind of de-powered him a little bit
that's just my opinion him and now
sylvia did have that moment where he's
like i think we're more powerful than we
think right but they're only powerful
together you gotta have them together to
make all this is true it takes you gotta
have a loki boo we also have doctor
strange this year because you know we've
seen doctors rage like we've never seen
him before as a demon man i i honestly
feel like they're setting up doctor
strange to be mephisto in the mcu
because maybe he has he literally has a
demon inside of him he's just he's
really struggling with his darkness
despite this darkness he's still a crazy
powerful being one of the most powerful
beings that we've ever seen in the mcu
so far definitely an up for a doctor
strange variant i agree like again we
haven't seen spider-man yet we don't
know what's happening in that movie but
he's he's just getting more and more
powerful and what if definitely showed
us that like he's got a lot of power and
he is using it no this is an interesting
one hawkeye because you know we were in
hawkeye season now it is hawkeye it's
the hawkeye holidays yes um yeah happy
hayley days in the hawkeye universe but
no hawkeye clinton barton himself
because we we do see that he over the
you know all of his time as an avenger
he's gotten deaf and so you know i'm
sure that has affected his ability to
you know do his job and to do things in
general but we do see him at his most
badass that we've ever seen him before
so i'm just like i think his deafness is
just a non-factor here he's just like i
just got booted up in terms of my skill
i feel yeah i think he's still really
good and he hasn't missed a step and if
anything this this show is making us
like him even more so i'll give him a
little up he's a little up right now
he's definitely doing up if he doesn't
make it home for christmas and he
betrays his children i don't know i'll
dump him down i'll dump him down he just
gets a new family at the end of this
like i don't need these people
i don't need this no imagine eleanor
eleanor convinces he starts dating
hawkeye oh if he marries eleanor that
that'll be my favorite thing to happen
on the show but who had the best year
from your perspective brandon you know
i'm ta when i boil it all down i think
about it how this year has ended how
it's ending i gotta think of how it
began this year i think should go to the
scarlet witch i think she
had the best year overall i mean a lot
has happened this year we've seen a lot
but man what a powerful year for her
really powered up
maybe becoming a villain who knows but i
think she had the the best year that
that would be my vote what about umt but
for me i think we're gonna have to go
with harley quinn because i really love
what they did with her in the suicide
squad and i just love that you know she
ended up killing that guy because she
was just like
you're killing kids and you're just a
bad dude and like i'm crazy but i know
the red flags of a really bad dude and
like i just love that you know her whole
entire arc was sort of like this whole
story about overcoming abuse and like i
just feel like that is something that
people need to see um in general
powerful stuff yeah i'm gonna give it to
you harley quinn there uh james gunn
knows how to write broken people you
heard it here first this is that's a
shocking a shocking answer i'm shocked
mt i love it i love it
thank you no jason just knows how to
write like uh you know nebula gamora all
those types like broken um people
yeah i feel he did a great job now it is
time for my favorite part of the show it
is time for a box of scraps with a box
of squares
scraps now brandon yes rob boxer scraps
question of the day what series or film
are you most looking forward to to 2022
because we are wrapping up the year we
gotta look forward yeah we gotta look
forward oh that's tough i mean there's
so many good things coming out next year
so excited we're gonna get so many more
star wars series some more marvel series
some more films uh got the dc's the
batman i mean that looks so good oh my
god yo i'm very excited for moon night i
think that's gonna be an awesome series
oscar yeah yeah i think the thing i'm
most excited for might be
thor four four eleven thousand thought
yeah i'm very excited to see you know
taika watigi come back make another thor
movie loved ragnarok i'm i'm super
pumped to see what this story is going
to tell us and like you know thor is one
of our last
final avengers left to see like okay
what's next for this guy i'm i'm very
excited to see what's going to happen
there what about you what what are you
most looking forward to in 2022 well i
am looking forward to thor 4 a lot uh
that's for sure um but all right i'm
gonna give two answers here um in terms
of film i'm gonna have to give it to
ant-man the wasp quantomania feel like
we're going to learn a lot about the mcu
um as a whole i mean and we're gonna
learn a lot of mcu science in that film
so i just i'm a sucker for that [ __ ] um
so i'm gonna say quantum mania and also
we're getting you know kang you got a
rumored modoc i don't know what's going
on there and apparently jim carrey is
rumored as modoc i don't know what's
going on there but if jim carries mohawk
i will scream the the project and series
that i'm most looking forward to is
invincible season two honestly yeah i
think that's coming out next year if
it's not i will be very upset but like
invisible season two is like invincible
season one ended so well and it's the
biggest cliffhanger ever and i just very
much care about what's going to happen
to adam eve because this is her show not
mark grayson's kidding now um i'm just i
just love that universe so much the
writing on that show is amazing and i
again i think this is the best show in
project superhero project of the entire
year to me personally so yeah i'm gonna
say invisible season two
come on let's get it amazon let's get it
i'm excited for everything let's do it
can't wait to talk more in 2022. dude
this year has been amazing for me like
getting to meet you and like everybody
at the new rockstars team has been like
phenomenal so like yeah i like i like
going back and reflecting yeah we're all
happy to be here yeah and we you know
this will be our last big question of
2021 but we will be back uh in 2022.
can't wait to see you guys again and
it's been it's been a blast doing these
with you mt what a year what a year it's
yeah it's been quite the year and i love
every second of it talking nerdy with
you brandon off screen never been on
screen in your life never ever be on
screen
guaranteed
and that is it for this episode of big
question of course big thank yous to
brandon the man that makes it all happen
for joining me on this episode please
follow him at grid and barrack he's an
amazing man you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] and wild theories
and you follow new rockstars here on
youtube and on all other social media
platforms and make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and also if you want to continue
the conversation our new rockstars
discord server is now open to the public
and we've made some channels available
to non-patrons so you can be part of the
broader community of new rockstars fans
on discord so if you're over 18 and
interested search for new rockstars
discord server and join the conversation
thank you guys so much again for
watching we love you guys so much and
we'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you